welcome back if you are looking for a
place to watch the game whether it's
raiders rebels or whoever you are
rooting for you should check out sickies
garage burgers and brews and they get a
cisco for sponsoring this segment and
let's welcome to the kitchen chad
duffield from sickies good to see you
buddy hey thank you okay the name
sickies burgers sickies grass burgers
what's what's the backstory on the name
sure the guys who came up with a concept
used to take sick days and hang out in
the garage and come up with crazy
burgers perfect it's perfect how many
different burgers do you guys have over
50 on the menu wow yeah so you opened up
a year ago i was there for opening
weekend or right about a year ago was
there how has the past year been for you
guys been terrific the community has
really supported us we've been fortunate
to support the community in certain
situations as well so it's been awesome
when it comes to watching a game you
guys have it dialed in you've got tvs
everywhere you have all the college
games you have all the nfl games dialed
in and you've got great food what's the
spread you have here in front of us
these are some of our top five burgers
of the summer so the one over there all
the way down
is one of our great ones obviously it is
stacked up with mac and cheese this is
our mac and cheeseburger right
wonderful this is a great appetizer
that's very popular at the restaurant we
call them pretzel fries served with a
beer cheese dip we make in-house those
are some of our wings what's better on a
game day than wings
standard buffalo of course nothing
standard about it but that's what the
back one is the front one is really fun
that is peanut butter and jelly sauce
okay spicy pb and j
and these are some of our other burgers
this one all the way in the front is our
maserati it is topped with cheese curds
marinara sauce and mozzarella cheese
this is our namesake burger the sickies
burger
it's beef american cheese bacon
egg onion rings sticky sauce and frank's
red hot as well so this one this one is
the one we're going to build today it's
called the black hole in celebration of
raiders fans all right let's do it our
raiders burger the black hole what goes
into it chad well first we're going to
start of course with a fresh baked bun
and then we're going to put on a burger
patty okay so go ahead and slide that
burger patty right on your burger
you don't use bare hands at sickies no
gloves on i'm making my own okay
absolutely then we want you to put some
fried jalapenos i'm going to get some
cheese curds that are cooking up for us
right now and tomorrow's national
cheeseburger day right yes and sickies
is a spot to celebrate national
cheeseburger day
these are some cheese curds right out of
the fryer check it out they're really
gooey notice chad is not putting the
cheese curds next to the burger they're
going on top of the burgers keep
building this thing up you got it gotta
put it on there perfect and put some of
our burger sauce on there we call it
sticky sauce it is a french fry slash
burger sauce it is mustard mayo
mayonnaise and pickle juice sauce looks
good and then you put it all together of
course
you slap it on top slap it on top
okay there you go
ready going for a bite here yeah get in
there all right
oh yeah awesome
good job thank you so much we appreciate
it thank you for having me you gotta
check out chickies we want to thank
cisco for sponsoring this segment
sickies garage burgers and brews town
square las vegas check them out at
sickiesburgers.com
rocky